this morning we're also learning new
details about a deadly plane crash in
Istanbul Turkey video shows the flight
landing in wet weather then disappearing
into a ditch
passengers scrambled to safety through a
gaping crack in the fuselage Roxana
Saberi has more the plane snapped into
three pieces after skidding off a wet
runway and dropping into a ditch the
impact of the crash was so strong the
front of the fuselage even flipped
upside down still most of the 183
passengers and crew on board managed to
survive some passengers helped one
another escape through a crack before
several of the injured were taken away
on a bus with no first responders in
sight this passenger says he was seated
in row 25 and the plane broke apart in
row 26 he says even though he was hurt
he guided other passengers to safety
security camera footage shows the planes
hard landing in the rain Istanbul
governor says the bad weather caused the
aircraft to slide off the runway this is
a third time a Boeing 737 flight run by
Turkey's Pegasus Airlines has skidded
off a runway in the past two years last
month at the same Istanbul Airport and
in 2018 a passenger plane came to a stop
just feet from the Black Sea in those
two incidents no one was injured for CBS
this morning Roxana Saberi London